problem they've scored ten points in  nine minutes Matthews moves it along  Luke oh the corner drain and is what the  doctor ordered pardon missed one  that's the state of affairs in the last  30 seconds which Houston having an  eight-point lead in cut to five and now  dr. Terry the first three from oof to  get some big on it steps back  uncompelled has gotten mighty loud in  here right now as the Mavericks have  scored six straight it's all been eight  straight pal 10 for Luka magic makes it  rain from there this time is going to go  inside and use that screen by DeAndre  capella switched on to Luka look at this  step  sir and then this one more put a row do  you say if you don't know now you know